تدخل القوات الإسرائيلية بالجرافات وسيارات الجيب المخيم
تحت جنح
الظلام، وقد أصبح هذا أمرًا روتينيًا،
وهذا هو الحطام المعتاد بعد ذلك،
والطرق الإسفلتية الركامية التي تم حرثها حتى التراب
بمجرد إصلاح الضرر، هناك
غارة أخرى والأمر نفسه في كل
مكان.  مرة أخرى، منذ ما يقرب من عامين،
تدور حرب منخفضة الحدة في
الضفة الغربية المحتلة. ويقول السكان هنا في
مخيم جنين للاجئين إنه كان هناك
أكثر من 30 توغلاً عسكرياً إسرائيلياً
منذ أغسطس من هذا
العام، ويعتبر المخيم موطناً لمسلحين
تتهمهم إسرائيل بارتكاب جرائم.  متورط في
هجمات على إسرائيليين ولكن هنا يُنظر إلى أولئك الذين
تصفهم إسرائيل بالإرهابيين على أنهم
مقاتلون ضد الاحتلال العسكري المستمر منذ عقود.
كوسكوس ليس مقاتلًا، فهو
يعمل لدى الحكومة المحلية في
غرفة الأطفال ولكن في الأسبوع الماضي استولى الجنود الإسرائيليون على
منزله خلال
غارة أخرى  وهو يريني حول بقايا
ما كان بمثابة أزمة حياة عائلية تحت
أحذيتنا، وندوب المعارك الماضية، وآثار
جدران المخيم، والحطام في كل
زاوية تقريبًا، تريني أم سامي الخراطيش الفارغة
على أرضية منزلها قائلة إن
القوات الإسرائيلية استخدمت هذه الغرفة لإطلاق النار  في
نهاية المطاف، سمح له الجنود
بالذهاب إلى الشارع، لكنهم أخذوا ابنها المتزوج حديثًا
بعد نهب غرفة نومه
بحثًا عن
أسلحة. تم إطلاق النار على محمود أبولي البالغ من العمر 18 عامًا
مساء الخميس الماضي عبر
نافذة غرفة نومه، وتروي والدته التي كانت تحمل
منشفة ملطخة بالدماء  كيف
لم يسمح الجنود الإسرائيليون للمسعفين بنقله
إلى
المستشفى، كنت متأكدة من أننا سنذهب إلى
المستشفى، تقول إننا نزلنا إلى الطابق السفلي
وكان هناك ضابط ثانٍ وجعل
المسعفين يضعون النقالة أرضًا، وكان
محمود ينزف حتى الموت أمام
منزله يوم الثلاثاء  وفي الليل، داهمت القوات الإسرائيلية
المخيم مرة أخرى، مما أدى إلى اندلاع معارك بالأسلحة النارية مع
المسلحين، وفي هذه العملية
قتلت القوات الإسرائيلية أربعة أشخاص على الأقل،
من بينهم هذا الصبي البالغ من العمر 8 سنوات، ثم
غادروا المخيم.